it was a rare announcement from iran's
atomic agency chief mohammed islami
commence which echo those made recently
by another senior government figure
it is no secret that we have become a
nuclear threshold state and this is a
reality it is also no secret that we
have the technical capabilities required
to manufacture a nuclear bomb
it would be an advancement of iran's
nuclear program far beyond the limits
outlined in a 2015 deal with the west i
am announcing today a deal abandoned by
former u.s president donald trump
at the united nations conference on
non-proliferation u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken criticized iran's
nuclear policy
iran remains on a path
of nuclear escalation
although it publicly claims to favor a
return to mutual compliance with the
jcpoa the joint comprehensive plan of
action
since march
iran has been either unwilling or unable
to accept a deal to achieve precisely
that goal
talks aimed at returning to the deal
have been stalled since march earlier
this week eu foreign policy chief joseph
burrell encouraged both sides to restart
negotiations putting a new proposed text
on the table
after reviewing the draft text it is
possible that in the near future we can
reach a conclusion regarding the time
table for the negotiations we will
probably see a new round of negotiations
negotiations to salvage the nuclear
accord began in april 2021 but have been
in deadlock since february
iran wants the u.s to lift all economic
sanctions and an assurance that the next
administration won't back out of the
accord but the biden administration says
guaranteeing the deal's survival beyond
2024 is impossible
and it wants confirmation that iran
won't enrich uranium to military grade
ali hashem al jazeera